Alex I was free from original re0 I grew
up in LA cañada California and between
Pasadena and La Crescenta a lot of
people don't know exactly where it is
but it's a small kind of bubble very
wealthy town yeah basically outside
Pasadena mm-hmm and I grew up with your
kids
oh yes yes both my parents were yes they
raised me how was how was your childhood
um some parts were good some parts were
bad my mom was a very violent alcoholic
you know very condescending violent you
know you know it was she was the type of
person that if I got a 95 on her test
she'd be like okay well you couldn't get
a hundred you know I just never felt
good enough so you know that kind of
messed with my self-esteem yeah and you
know when she got drunk she was very
violent she knew how to scrap yeah so so
it was I was kind of rough at some
points you know and then where'd you
life go when you left home
well actually I I got kicked out when I
was 19 right after high school I got
held back in sixth grade and two months
out of high school my dad passed away
and I moved back home and then I went to
Santa Barbara City College to try to get
a degree in about 2000 and
I believe he passed away 2010 so and how
did have done here um so basically I
started using heroin in Santa Barbara
of course it got dry I knew somebody
down here they could get some I went on
vacation with my mom to San Diego and my
friend drug dealer wasn't picking up and
I was sick and so I didn't know what to
do and I just draw it literally took her
car drove three hours from San Diego
unbeknownst to her to Skid Row
driving around asking people you know
where I can get this that this to talk
to you why did it take you longer than
two minutes to find it it literally it
probably took about maybe yeah ten
minutes you know
ten minutes and yeah so and that's what
started it and then are you saying down
here no I'm not staying down here here's
not here yeah unfortunately yeah yeah so
where do you live go other than not
Pasadena okay and are you working at all
I used to work at PF Changs for two
years and in order for me to get sober I
decided to quit but that didn't really
work out but I actually of course drug
addicts have a plan but I have these
medications that will help me get on
something called suboxone which you can
wean yourself off of and so that was the
main reason coming down here you know is
to you know try to help me get sober
so I'm looking in the next week
hopefully to get sober and really like
do this thing I'm miserable yeah it's
very is so sucking you know I would use
it over the span of seven years you know
on and off longest I had so it was 16
months and do your hair so you're using
heroin my dad never knew before he died
he never smoked weed but I yes my mother
does no unfortunately nobody
would I do for money another long story
cramp has passed away
they had a trust fund for me since my
dad wasn't alive the trust went to
natural-born Berta's which is my last
name so my mom didn't get it so my
brother and I you know in every year we
got 5% of the money from this trust and
at first when I was sober it was it was
great I was doing good and then the
second I relapsed you know my habit was
out of control no no yeah that's a
blessing in disguise so I'm hoping this
next year you know that's what I'm
trying to get clean right now it's so
like I don't start the next year with
all this money and just you know blow it
all and waste why my life man I love my
life I don't hate the way I'm living
right now do you ever give any
relationships with anybody
I mean dear friends you have a
girlfriend like that
I actually yeah I did have an ex girl I
did have a girlfriend um you know she
cheated on me I kicked her out and
actually my best friend just passed away
on the 23rd his funeral was yesterday
and yeah so it's and then I found out
this morning that my brother is a gnarly
alcoholic my dad passed away in his arms
and they said that he has his liver so
bad that he has a 50-50 chance of dying
in the next
days so we were all just praying for him
and you know it's all so surreal it's
all like holy [ __ ] man like that's
another reason why I want to shape up
you know if your friend s awake
they found him next to a meth pipe which
is strange because usually don't people
don't pass away from a meth pipe you
know so my homegirl thinks it was laced
with fentanyl or something but we don't
know and I'm not about to ask his family
yeah well good luck with everything
yeah you know I grew up from a
relatively you know wealthy family I had
opportunities like no other and I still
do and I'm you know just it doesn't mean
you're beautiful I need to have that
attic you know everybody exactly so yeah
absolutely
thank you so much